Film Courage: How important is it for a writer
to know their own personal story?
Not simply the story they’re writing but
who they are?
Their own life journey?
Karl Iglesias: So if you’re talking for
a writer, I would think it’s not that important?
Film Courage: No?
Karl Iglesias: No.
I know it might be surprising to hear, but
to me it’s not that important?
Film Courage: Why not?
Karl Iglesias: The thing you [as a writer]
should be aware of is human dynamics.
You know, psychology, emotions, character
relationships.
That you should be well-versed in.
Now, lucky is the writer that has had an amazing
life experience and has had all those experiences
that he can write about.
That makes it easier.
But it’s not necessary, if you’re a highly
curious person.
I mean you could be a great writer that has
had a very mediocre life.
I’m not a believer of the Hemingway thing,
you know, where if you want to write about
adventure, you’ve got to go and be adventurous.
Maybe there is some truth to it but I think
it really depends on your mind and your curiosity.
And I think we can all find…it’s all in
your imagination.
If you’re highly imaginative you can write
about anything, whether you experience it
or not.
If you write science fiction, George Lucas
didn’t experience going on a ship in order
to be able to write about it, right?
Or James Cameron?
Do you think all that stuff about Pandora
and AVATAR that he experienced that in his
own life…no!
It’s all imagination, right?
So that’s what you need to know.
You need to have high imagination, obviously.
But then you need to be well-versed in character
relationships.
So yes.
If you had experience with character relationships,
that’s great (character conflicts).
But if you haven’t, you can always learn
it.
And if you’re highly-curious…I mean I
have a psychology degree, so if I wasn’t
a writer, I’d be a psychologist.
Because that is what fascinates me.
I’m fascinated my human interactions, psychology
and especially the reason why people do what
they do, which is what characters do in stories.
So really, that works for me.
But my life story, as much as I consider it
very unique and different from most people’s
life stories, I don’t have the desire to
write about it.
So it doesn’t affect me at all in that sense.
Film Courage: So someone shouldn’t totally…well…let
me just rephrase that.
Karl Iglesias: I think I understand what you’re
saying.
Maybe it might be different for actors because
that is usually what you’re taught, you
have to use your sense memory and that kind
of thing.
But for writers, I don’t think there is
a Yes or a No.
For me, I don’t think it’s important.
It doesn’t have to be.
For others it might be.
And I’m aware that if it did happen to you
and you want to write about it, then of course
that makes it easier as it happens, you’ll
me a lot more realistic.
Film Courage: Well you talked about today
that when you gave your class, many people
noted that they wanted to write their own
story.
Karl Iglesias: A lot of people are writing
that.
That’s because they think that their life
stories are interesting.
Film Courage: Everyone thinks their life story
is interesting.
Karl Iglesias: Right.
Everyone thinks they’re the hero of their
own story and there is a little truth to it.
But I have to say if I’m talking from experience
from hearing people’s stories that they
want to write as movies, I would say that
90 percent of them are not that interesting.
The writers themselves think it’s interesting.
I don’t think it’s interesting and audiences
don’t think it’s interesting.
So they’ve got to learn that.
That’s where feedback comes in.
If the feedback is “Okay, well you know?”
I mean I always bring out Hitchcock’s quote
about “Drama is real life without all the
boring parts cut out.”
So a lot of people feel that just because
they’ve had a few interesting experiences
(maybe unique) that it warrants them to making
a movie.
They may be right, but a lot of times they
are not.
Film Courage: I’ve found that some people
who have had incredibly interesting (albeit
hard lives) actually don’t think they are
that interesting.
And that the reverse is actually the case.
The people who have had “Oh yes and this
person said this and this happened.”
etc. and that [easy or charmed life story]
is not actually that exciting.
But I’ve talked to several people and their
lives have been very difficult and challenging
and they don’t really see it as anything
interesting.
And I’m always encouraging them [to write
about their lives].
Karl Iglesias: That’s where feedback comes
in!
Film Courage: And these people are like “No.
This is boring.”
Karl Iglesias: Because if they hear everybody
telling them, eventually they will believe
it.
So…get feedback.
Film Courage: Interesting…
Question for the Viewers: What are your thoughts
on a writer knowing their personal story?